쉑쉑버거가 1호점이 이쪽으로 다시
이전을 한다고 합니다
제가 오늘은
강남역에 와 있는데 뒤에 보이는 건물
아마 여러분들 많이 아실 겁니다 비랑
김태희 부부가 매입한 건물 앞에 와
있는데 지금 뒤에 보시면 이렇게 좀
공사를 하고 있어요 여기서 최근에
아마 기사가 좀 많이 나가는데 그
쉑쉑버거가 1호점이 이쪽으로 이전을
한다고 합니다
원래 이제 건너편에 1호점이 있었는데
임대료를 약 한 1억 정도에
들어와서
임차 계약을 했다는 내용에 좀 기사가
많이 나가는데 그래서 제가 이전한다고
해서 여기 현장에 좀 와 있습니다
그래서 지금 이쪽 거리에 지금
쉑쉑버거 1호점 이쪽으로 들어오고 그
다음에 저쪽으로 가면 5가이즈 한국
1호점이 저쪽에 들어올 예정이고
그리고 저쪽 신논현 쪽으로 좀 더
가면은
슈퍼두퍼 또 그쪽에 또 들어와
있습니다 어떻게 보면 좀 의도치 않게
햄버거 거리가
됐는데 좀 되게 신기해요 그래서
만약에 쉑쉑버거 이쪽에 오면은 지금
5가이즈도 이제 곧 오픈을 할 건데
어디가 과연 장사가 제일 잘 될지
그것도 좀 되게 궁금한 포인트인 것
같습니다
어디서 일단 좀 건물 얘기를 좀 더
하자면 김태희
BC 부부가
2021년에
920원에게 좀 매입을 했는데 그때
돼지 평단가로 봤을 때는 약 한 6억
3천 정도 됩니다 많은 분들이
작년이랑 올해 초에 제가 그전에 올래
영상 올렸던 거에
악플이 너무 많이 달렸어요 그래서
악플이 너무 많이 달려가지고
그때 이제
기사 나간 것 중에 하나가
b랑 김태희 부부 빌딩 투자 망했다
400억 손실 봤다 해가지고 기사가
굉장히 많이 나가는데 제가
영상을 올린 일에
댓글을 처음 닫았어요
악플이 너무 많아 가지고
근데 지금 물론 강남역에 임대 상황이
썩 좋진 않아요 지금 여기도 보시면은
공실 부분도 있고 저쪽에도 공실이
굉장히 많은데 지금이 건물은 현재
만실 상태고 건물이 지금
높게 더 앉아 있어요 그래서 용적률이
꽉 차 있지 않습니다 그래서 지금
여기 그
용도지역이 일반상업지역인데
일반상업지역은
용적률이 최대 800%거든요 지금이
건물 같은 경우에는 아직 그
500%가 안 됩니다 그래서 건물도
디벨롭을 할 만한 그런 좀 가능성도
있기 때문에 저 개인적으로는
강남대로 있는 빌딩이
메모리 거의 안 나와요 저도 일한지
꽤 됐지만 이쪽에 이제 거래된게 많이
없거든요
매물도 좀 안 나오고 그래서 저
개인적으로는 그래도 좀 잘한 투자라고
좀 생각이 드는데 일단은
조금 더 지켜봅시다 너무 이제 얘기가
많았어 가지고
조금 더 지켜보면 좋을 거 같고이
두부부의 빌딩이
6억 3천 정도의 산 건데 상업지
치고 위치 대비했을 때 괜찮게
매입했다라고 저 개인적으로
생각하거든요 그리고 강남역이 지금
상황이 좀 좋지는 않지만 나중에 좀
어떻게
변할지도 좀 지켜보시면 좋을 것
같습니다
5가 이제 있는 쪽으로 한번 가보시죠
[음악]
네 저는 지금 손예진 씨가 매입한
건물 앞에 와 있습니다 그래서
강남대로 바로 이면에 먹자도로
메인에 위치한 건물이고 그리고 또
코너 땅이에요
근데 위치가 굉장히 좋습니다 그래서
돼지가
84평인데
매입가가 무려 244억입니다 그래서
돼지 평단가로 봤을 때 한 2억 9천
정도 해서
원래 한 3층 정도 되는 건물을
매입해 가지고 지금 멸시를 해서
건물을 짓고 있고요 여기 지금
규모를 지하 1층에 주상 5층 규모로
지금
지을 예정이고 지금 용도는 다 이제
근생으로 만들 예정입니다 그래서 여기
뭐 자리가 워낙 좋기 때문에
임대는 뭐 공실 없이 채워질 것으로
좀 예상이 되고 어떻게 신축이 될지
좀 지켜보시면 좋을 것 같고
원래 그 전에 손예진 씨가 신사동에
160억 정도 되는 빌딩을 샀었어요
그거는 뭐 따로 건축행위는 안 했었고
그리고 그 앞전에
합정동에 있는 건물을 싸게 사서 좀
그래도 시세차익을 보고 매각을
했습니다 아무래도 이제 부동산 투
일가견이 있으신 거 같고 그래서 지금
뒤에 보이는이 건물도 좀 어떻게
신축을 하고 어떤 임대를 마칠지
나중에 매각은 어떻게 할지 지켜보시면
좋을 것 같습니다